in my younger days I found
undecidability hard to get to grips with
so what I thought I would do was to try
and go back a little historically and do
so much as I can about undecidability to
lead back up to Turing and hopefully
make it easier for those of you who are
struggling with the concept to find some
way to internalize it and get to
understand it for yourself because
that's the important thing you need to
hear about undecidability from as many
different roots as possible and
eventually you'll get one that's just
right for you alright then what was the
earliest undecidable problem how did it
rear its ugly head well I wouldn't want
to go on record and say that this is the
earliest but it's a very very very
long-standing an old one round about 300
BC very bright Greek gentleman called
Euclid invented plain geometry angles
triangles circles lines straight lines
the whole lot he wrote three books of
tutorial stuff on geometry and in fact I
remember being told by my master either
when he was taught this stuff he was
told he was not learning geometry he was
learning Euclid that's how important
Euclid was so he had three books and his
so-called propositions his basic given
things on which he built the geometry
we're known as Euclid's propositions
there were lots of these and mostly they
were unconscious because they all linked
together beautifully you know one thing
led to another if you're accepted that
the three angles in a triangle added up
to 180 degrees then you could rigorously
show that the exterior angle down at the
bottom was the sum of the two opposite
interior ones things like that one thing
led to another is fine except one
proposition stuck out like a sore thumb
there's a so-called parallel lines
proposition what Euclid's proposition 5
says is this when you have two lines
that are intersected by this third line
if these marked and
all's add up to 180 degrees then the two
original lines are parallel and they
will never meet and it was a source of
absolute anguish to mathematicians over
the centuries they just couldn't prove
it in the early 18th century a gentleman
called Girolamo Sakaki said okay that's
90 and that's 90 I've drawn basically
three sides of a rectangle now how can I
finish off that rectangle could I sort
of make this line slope in a bit and
that one slope in a bit and do this
right so you get an acute angle there or
can we make it roll over at the top and
complete it with an bigger obtuse angle
or do we just do the absolutely sensible
thing and draw a clean straight line
across the top at another 90 degrees
what he tried to do was to show that if
you allowed it to go acute or obtuse
then it led to a contradiction so he did
the so-called obtuse case and he was
quite convinced it was it got a fabulous
proof that he led to contradiction no he
hadn't it made a unwarranted assumption
then he tried to do the acute case and
that really was skull-cracking
and he had to admit that his own proof
that it led to a contradiction he didn't
really believe it but he was determined
to do it and he tried to write a book
called Euclid without flaws it was going
to show that any other geometry other
than Euclidean was absolutely not on if
you couldn't prove proposition 5 maybe
it was an optional extra maybe it could
be true for Euclidian geometry maybe
there were other geometries where he
needn't be true it was optional well
when it came to seriously smart
mathematicians in the early 18th century
believe me none came more seriously
small than carl friedrich gauss like his
predecessor about a hundred years ago
here in the UK Isaac Newton Gauss and
Newton shared the most unfortunate
of social skills they were unbelievably
sensitive to criticism they were
monstrously talented both of them
certainly in english-speaking world of
course Newton's the better-known name of
the two but boy is Gauss right up there
with noon and gauss's and national hero
he is the equivalent of Newton if you
like in Germany without a doubt and
deservedly so
so anyway Gow started to take a look at
this problem but like Newton II hated
publishing if you published then the
great unwashed would start telling you
that what you've done was an affront to
nature and was downright wrong even when
they had no mathematical skills
whatsoever gaffs had this name for them
which I can't pronounce but I know that
one of you put me right he called them
the oceans when from a province in
Greece called bozo where the inhabitants
are supposed to be remarkably slow on
the uptake and dull and he wrote to one
of his friends in a private letter and
said I am NOT going to publish this work
I fear the reaction of the borough
shion's I think that's how you pronounce
it you don't have a similar thing many
of you will know he invented calculus
kept it secret all to himself and then
was utterly affronted when Leibniz
independently discovered it oh there are
allegations of plagiarism also not so
you may be seriously smart but somebody
slightly less smart than you will
eventually get there well this sort of
observation came to hit Gauss eventually
he didn't want to publish this work and
some say well it wasn't the oceans that
he was frightened of it was another
monstrous presence Immanuel Kant the
very famous philosopher now those of you
who follow as a Monty Python and the
Philosopher's song will know all about
Immanuel Kant he was the one who was
very rarely stable and I think that's
about right Kant had gone on record as
saying that any idea that space was not
utterly Euclidean and flat and beautiful
in all its dimensions was completely
wrong it was basically an argument I
think that went on the lines of trust me
I'm a Phillips
I know it is flat and Gauss knew darn
well you can't just dismiss can't but
you start publishing and get into a
flame war with with can't it could go on
for years and Gauss wanted to get on
with his work
so he feared that it would cause huge
eruptions if this came out cows are
basically just did the almost obvious
thing so well what happens if three
angles in a triangle don't add up to 180
now if they add up to less then
basically airlines are innately slightly
curved inwards and you end up with
what's now called hyperbolic geometry if
on the other hand they're ever so
slightly convex those lines you end up
with what's called spherical or more
generally ellipsoidal geometry and he
had it all worked out he could solve any
problem in any of these geometries
and knew they were all related to each
other by the middle 1820s another
gentleman comes on the scene well known
to some of you he's Nikolai Ivanovich
Lobachevsky he did work on this and
published it in I think about 1826 1829
somewhere around there yes two papers in
those two years and the roof did not
fool him
everybody just studiously ignored it
perhaps even more upsetting really for
Gauss was that one of Gauss's long-term
friends another mathematician was called
Wolfgang Bolyai and Bolly I himself had
tried like Zachary to prove that it must
be flat it must be Euclidian he couldn't
succeed in proving that because it just
ain't true that's why but his son
janosh wally i wrote an appendix to one
of his father's books in basically what
he did was he just rediscovered all the
Gauss had done but he didn't know it the
elder Bolyai sends the book to Gauss and
said please look at the appendix Gauss
please please praise my son he's done
the most wonderful things and Gauss with
the sort of social skills as only here
in Newton possess said my dear friend I
cannot possibly praise your son's work
because to do so would be to praise
myself and that would be immodest you
see I did all of this years ago
what may be true but it's not actually
exactly the most tactful way to put it
there was then a general acceptance that
yes non-euclidean geometries absolutely
fine you could get them to work
excellently the final unification wasn't
done until the 1860s by a man called
Eugene Beltrami but yes it was all part
of the same story in elliptical gaze I
mean to exaggerate it of course and to
draw it like that
your lies that you draw which you think
of parallel are actually grossly
exaggerated like that because the innate
curvature of space forces them to be
like that now you still join them up and
you can still say at that instant it is
in some sense perpendicular right there
so that's a two-dimensional exaggeration
of elliptical here's Euclidean and
here's hyperbolic notice that the
hyperbolic case parallel lines always
actually diverge from each other
everywhere they do not meet the
elliptical well you know all about that
and it's a very good model the earth is
not a perfect sphere but let's imagine
it is but on that sphere if Sean and I
start walking due north and we keep our
angles with the equator rigidly the same
as each other then the innate curvature
of the earth so long as you are taking
sightings and going Juno's all the time
we meet at the North Pole in the
hyperbolic geometry case they never meet
here was something that really was
beginning to rattle mathematicians the
parallel postulate number five that
Euclid had come up with was not provable
within Euclid's systems of propositions
and yet it was true so you had for the
first time the innate mathematical shock
that put you off your food for days
probably that there could be something
in a system of propositions that wasn't
through
the propositions in some sense were not
strong enough by the end of the 19th
century a lot of people say hey this is
all very wonderful you know Gauss Bolyai
Lobachevsky sorted out by Beltrami nice
job but it's just mathematicians playing
with silly ideas isn't it doesn't apply
to the real world oh yes it does
because starting with a young Protege of
Gauss's called Bernhard Riemann very
famous for the Riemann hypothesis he
investigated all sorts of topological
surfaces called manifolds oh boy this
non Euclidean geometry was just vital
for doing work on this and at the turn
around the beginning of the 20th century
a lot of you I think anticipate this one
coming Albert Einstein by the time he
got on to general relativity Albert
Einstein was able to say even if space
was totally flat and Euclidian with no
matter in it whatsoever
my general relativity requires that the
moment you put mass into space it
distorts the curvature of space-time and
you get non-euclidean geometries
occurring it wasn't just mathematicians
playing games
it was physicists saying we need this
stuff in order to understand the
universe we really have to understand
this what did it actually do for the
mental well-being of mathematicians some
thought oh this parallel lines thing
it's a one-off special care you see
won't happen again
Hilbert was really worried about it he
visited Euclidean geometry and showed
that there were all sorts of flaky bits
to it even beyond proposition 5 not that
they couldn't be repaired you know
Euclid just assumes that we all know
what a circle is and stuff like that so
Hilbert felt so strongly that at the on
his retirement day in the early 20th
century he said he cared so much about
the entscheidungsproblem the decision
problem and basically what he said
something like
via Kenan visum via Masana listen we can
no we must no he wasn't saying that he
wanted all the tough problems in
mathematics to be magically solved you
know his firm as Last Theorem true we
know now that it is he didn't know that
or is the Goldbach conjecture you know
an even number is the sum of two prime
numbers
it wasn't saying I want them solving
right now but what it was saying was
when you do solve them please come to me
and say yes or no true or false
give me an answer even if it's the
answer is 42 do not come to me and start
saying it's undecidable we're not having
that we're going to have a program in
mathematics which is going to make the
foundations of mathematics so rigorous
that everything will be decided true or
false
I'm enjoying myself here I hope that's
over there's a whole thing H+ now I
wanted you to do this one for a long
time actually